das haben wir mal die schwarze nämlich
schwarzer bist
und dann ist das so brutal langsam der
OBI und diese Zimmer Gas
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim Sport Podcast
des österreichischen Bundesheers heute
zu Gast gefeiter Matteo Fleischmann und
Johannes Aigner unsere erfolgreichsten
para Skifahrer des Landes herzlich
willkommen
zu der vergangenen Saison die natürlich
großartig war Weltmeisterschaft die
Paralympics in Peking alles abgeräumt
vor allem die Paralympics war natürlich
super man sieht dich Matteo hier in
Uniform du bist als gefreuter schon beim
Bundesheer als Johannes du kommst erst
im April dazu dann wirst du nämlich 18
aber auf jeden Fall seid ihr schon Teil
des österreichischen Fernsehen
auch in der heutigen Saison großartig
ein aber schauen wir noch einen einmal
zurück äh lieber Johannes wie war das
denn so die vergangene Saison für dich
ja die Saison weil mich wir sind
Märchenbuch kann man sagen angefangen
mit wem das Sommer weiß ja
laufen können
dann darauf halt dann gleich die
Paralympics wo er mit der mit dem ersten
Rennen gleich gut drinnen war die waren
die Paralympics natürlich auch wie also
Märchenbuch und one dafür dann auch
leichter zum fahren weil der Druck weg
war noch im ersten Rennen und ich glaube
deswegen ist San die Paralympics dann so
gut ausgegangen fünf Medaillen bei den
Paralympics zahlreiche Weltmeisterschaft
noch das ist eben keine karrierebilanz
sondern eine saisonanz von der
vergangenen Johannes ein bisschen jetzt
17 Nummer ist nicht viele älter das ist
ja fast schon unglaublich was ihr schon
so früh erreicht habt
ja ich bin eigentlich eher jetzt ganz
kurzen Empfang was für Märchen ist und
das dann eigentlich wenn die Schöne und
das Biest oder
ja ja
wer ist Matteo wie hast du das aus der
Perspektive eines geiles empfunden du
musst natürlich als Guide Vorfahren
johannes hat eine starke Sehbehinderung
das heißt er muss sich komplett auf dich
verlassen weil sie so in die Saison
gestartet seid und die WM schon aber gut
gegangen ist hast Du gewusst das wird
gut ja also mir war immer klarer Hans
ist der geiler Skifahrer da war es wohl
darauf ankommt und war da schon wieder
Vorbereitung von das ist Sohn das ist
nicht so blöd was man dann spätestens
bei der WM hatte sie dann wirklich
ausgestellt das nicht blöd war und zum
Abschluss dann die Olympiade hat das
ganze nochmal bestätigt so gemein und ja
grundsätzlich ist meine Aufgabe
eigentlich nur die dass sie am sicher
von A nach B also vom Start ins Ziel
bringen und mehr oder weniger als Anzug
was sie normal mit meiner Augen beim
Skifahren wahrnehmen was er ja nicht
sich
Johannes mit Matteo ist jetzt
international unterwegs das ist in dem
Sinne gleich der erste Guide mit dem du
international groß aufgetreten bist und
es hat doch großartig funktioniert aber
wie wichtig ist diese Rolle des Geistes
für dich beim Skifahren ja das ist
natürlich sehr wichtig das haben wir
auch so gesehen ja meine Augen in dem
Sinne und werde Matthias erste
Kurs dort ist okay sofort funktioniert
und das ist ja bis heute eigentlich
geblieben und ich glaube deswegen
funktioniert
dazu sagen wir verstecken uns wirklich
gut miteinander ist
schraubiger Bruder
aber trotzdem gern
und na wir verstehen uns jetzt nicht nur
auf der Pisten gut weil gerade in
unserer Beziehung da kommt jetzt nicht
nur darauf Training Training Training
sondern so das Vertrauen ist ja wirklich
großer Grundstein weil er mir
wortwörtlich blind vertrauen muss und
ich sag Grad Hocke und ich lag an hocken
vor der gerade in der Hocke in Meter 101
seine so ist es Vertrauen und deswegen
wir verstehen
gemeinsam noch ein Skifahren und das ist
glaube das was wirklich was ausmacht ich
glaub das ist das auch wirklich
relevante gibt es auch geil Teams was
einfach sportlich super passt aber sie
sich eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
ausstellen können
wie man es könnte funktionieren das
waren was jetzt nicht auskommt weil es
ist trotzdem Sport aber es macht halt
wesentlich einfach
weil ich heute einfach ganz genau was
wie dick da was geht da in dem Gasthaus
Dom eigentlich wirklich gut teilweise
man immer verstehe sehr nett mit einem
genauso geht aber das macht dann einfach
einfach mal sehr gute trainingsbeziehung
ist und nicht nur auf
Trainingsschwerpunkt sondern auch
freundschaftlich gut funktioniert jetzt
hast du Johannes der Matte gefunden oder
seid so schnell gefunden worden aber es
ist meine geistsuche kann auch mühsam
sein und
daneben gehen wie glücklich bist du dass
das bei euch geklappt hat
dann doch schwanger weiß muss ja vom
technischen her oder bzw vom schicken
können natürlich Herzform passen und
dadurch dass der Matteo vorher schon
viel gefahren ist war der Grundsteuer
schon da und das ist so gut funktioniert
hat
das ist einfach
sehr stark Windows Boost hast auf das
kannst du verlassen und das war dann
auch relativ wichtig weil wenn man
gesehen hat wann ich zum Beispiel
irgendwo Probleme hat beim Training was
der Matteo genau wo es meistens liegt
und wir einmal helfen kann
immer ein bisschen hinten drinnen hat
und deswegen kann man relativ gut helfen
und du bist einmal oder vielleicht sogar
ein paar Mal auch mit deiner Schwester
gefahren die auch geil ist für deine
andere Schwester
und da hat es nicht so ganz geklappt
oder den Kundendienst gemacht hat seine
Monate
mir ist und mit mir nicht trainieren
können
mit riesig gefahren
war dann wieder froh dass der Matteo
zurückgehst
das hat gar nicht funktioniert da hebt
man glaube ich nicht einmal von
opfertreten brauchen wird es ausgeschaut
hat beim fahren
ja da das lassen wir lieber glaube
ich besser auf der Piste zusammen aber
das Geld Thema ist natürlich
Behindertensport Matteo der johannes hat
schon angesprochen du bist selber
gefahren du warst in verschiedensten
landeskadern ein sehr guter Skifahrer
als dann die Möglichkeit kam Guide zu
werden wie schnell hast du gesagt das
klingt spannend das mache ich ich habe
schon ehrlich gesagt anfangszeitung
überlegt
war ja relativ das war noch nicht lange
her dass sie wirklich selber aufgehört
habe und ich habe ja nicht deswegen
aufgeht weil kein Spaß mehr gehabt habe
oder wie gesagt habe das ist
aussichtslos sondern man muss schon
sagen Skifahren ist finanziell große
Rolle und gerade im Alter von 15 16
Jahren ist es dann ja auch von der
Eltern das zum stemmen und da mal
10-15000 pro so einfach so Herzen gehen
für Skifahren kann sie auch nicht jeder
leisten und das muss man schon sagen und
das war mit der großer Grund warum ich
gesagt habe ich auch weil mir die Server
für Druck gemacht hat dass meine Eltern
da so viel investieren müssen und wieder
dann das Angebot komme ist vom Ansehen
heute ist eigentlich so ein bisschen am
Anfang ehrlich gesagt das genutzt ich
kann dem Skifahren treu bleiben weil es
ist wirklich meine größte Leidenschaft
ja erst noch den ersten Kurs hat sie
denn dann eigentlich Feier ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube
das Problem
von hinten zum jagten mit einer Rüden
black sagt und am zweiten Tag glaube das
haben wir die schwarze nämlich
schwarze bist
und dann ist das so brutal langsam der
OBI
irgendwas
also wirklich total gleich zum Stehen
ist zum normalen Skifahren teilweise
sogar für mich mittlerweile wurde da
jetzt länger dabei bin fast sogar
überzuordnen weil du das normaler Mensch
sagst mir geht's gut da ist alles dann
passt die Kamera drauf verlassen sowieso
wirklich nur auf das was ich sage und
jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen dass
da jeder von uns sei
zwar nicht damit 50 60 70 km/h vor fühle
mich ganz wohl jeder hat sicher schon
mal einen gescheit nebligen Tag erlebt
wo man nichts mehr sieht
man fühlt man sie immer sowohl bei 60 17
fangt auch langsam zu dem rutschen und
das ist eigentlich genau das wissen was
vergleichen kann für mich jeder Tag
anheblicher Tag und deswegen muss man im
Renner war dann trotzdem schnell sein
und alles geben umso wichtiger eben das
Vertrauen auf dich jetzt äh du gesagt du
wolltest dem Skifahren treu bleiben das
war dann für dich die Möglichkeit und
dann kam die große Überraschung das ist
ja nicht nur Skifahren das ist wirklich
Racing also wirklich Rennen fahren das
riecht das lange adoptieren müssen oder
ging das dann doch schnell nein relativ
schnell gegangen weil sie eben gesagt
und nicht so lange her war dass sie
wirklich selber oft gehört habe und ja
wir sind
auf meinem vorigen trainingszug sag
einmal doch nur in dem Rhythmus drin war
gleich aufgesprungen
gearbeitet und das hat sie gut auszahlt
mittlerweile hast du paralympische
Italiener bei dir daheim im Kasten
liegen du auch Johannes bei dir war der
Weg schon ein bisschen vorgegeben bei
dir eben überraschend
Leuten für dich die Medaille Matteo also
ich sage immer so sie bedeuten so viel
dass es daheim im safe-expert habe und
gar nicht im Kasten
das wegkommen was er paranoid ist
ehrlich gesagt aber na so eine riesen
Bedeutung weil sie sind halt einfach ah
die Bestätigung von unzähligen Stunden
die du nicht nur auf der Piste
verbringst sondern einen der Kraftkammer
und nur dazu im Auto das darf man nicht
vergessen was wir da im Jahr an
Kilometer und Stunden im Auto verbringen
ist doch große Rolle Johannes du hattest
wahrscheinlich das Ziel schon von klein
auf man weiß ja deine gesamte Familie
sehr schiebegeistert deine Schwester
Veronika schon sehr früh Anzeichen
gemacht dass sie ganz nach vorne fahren
möchte oft war mal das Alter das Leben
glaube ich das große Problem dass sie
nicht schon viel früher erfolgreich war
dann du und deine Schwester Barbara noch
hinterher gekommen beide auch jetzt
wahnsinnig erfolgreich war das für dich
immer klar ich werde paralympia
auf das ist einfach das Haupttyp das ist
bei jedem Training es wieder immer
darauf konkret überhaupt dann bei die
man zwei ja vor die Paralympics da wird
dann schon da werden schon die Maßstäbe
gesetzt außer gefüttert wer kennt dabei
die Paralympic sola mitfahren und dann
wird heute wirklich nur auf die drauf
gearbeitet das ist eigentlich immer das
Hauptthema bei wieder Analysen oder beim
Training und
wieder mal diese schon gesagt das ist
dann halt einfach Bestätigung dass sie
die Trainings Austritt haben und du hast
dann heute vor Ort wie ein Hogen auf
deiner Listen waren
[Musik]
das ist einfach dann nach oben auf der
Listen was sagst du hast es zu erreichen
hast und
das ist dann eigentlich so gut
ausgefallen ist ich muss glaube ich
leider nicht
aber jetzt im Skifahren sozusagen
aufgewachsen wie früh war die klar dass
du der beste Skifahrer in der
fahrersportwelt werden möchtest klar ich
glaube das ist erst kämen wir dann mit
ersten worko brennen gefahren sind sie
dann erst wo du überhaupt stehst weil
vorher kommst du mit die Leute nicht
wirklich in Kontakt mit dir eigentlich
vor mir ist das schlussendlich dann und
äh das war dann halt mehr immer so war
langsames hier arbeiten kann
jeden jeden Sport gemacht und den dann
halt Flexa drauf gearbeitet
Alex
dann halt schon dass mit der Elli dann
ermöglich ist und mit der Einstellung
kann man dann eigentlich
jetzt weiß man dass man als Guide im
Endeffekt genauso Spitzenleistungen
fahren muss wie der Athlet selbst das
erfordert natürlich auch Vorbereitung
das war immer die große Problematik dass
erfolgreiche
Sportlerinnen und Sportler mit
Sehbehinderung dann zwar irgendwann
abgesichert waren auch durch diese
verschiedenen System über die Guides
noch nicht wichtig ist dass du jetzt
durch deine Guide Position auch beim
Bundesheer sein kannst und im Endeffekt
genauso wie der Johannes dem Training
voll und ganz dich widmen kannst und
nicht arbeiten gehen muss nebenbei ja
also wie gesagt da ist mir schon ein
riesen Star vom Herzen gefallen an immer
riesengroßes Dankeschön jemand ans
Bundeswehr dass die das ermöglicht haben
weil eben wie schon erwähnt war das
vorher nicht möglich und man muss ja
sagen was geht ab genau den gleichen
Trainings auf und wer
muss die gleiche Zeit opfern stehen
Normalfall mit gleich viel Motivation
und Engagement da und das macht dann
natürlich nur viel schwieriger wenn er
jetzt wo unterkommen kann und gefährdet
wird und du aber nebenbei irgendwie mit
einem Fuß im Sport stehst und wenn
anderen Fuß privat arbeiten gehen musst
und da ist jetzt das vom Bundesheer
natürlich ein Traum weil es ein
abgesichert wir können uns voll und ganz
auf dem Sport konzentrieren und wie man
sich funktioniert und zweites
hoffentlich Johannes glaubst du dass man
mittlerweile bei euch im Skifahren als
nicht Profi überhaupt noch diese
Leistungen zu bringen kann weiß nicht
wofür kann man das nicht vorstellen weil
sonst doch sehr viel Training drin
und du da nicht mit vorhin Engagement
oder mit Überzeugung oder dabei bist
mal wirklich nicht vorstellen dass du
für mich fast weil es Niveau in die
letzten Jahre
um einiges gestiegen ist und
Nacht vorstellen dass da irgendwas
möglich wart das heißt wir stellen uns
auch in dieser Saison die ja schon
großartig begonnen hat für euch auf
große Erfolge ein aber jetzt ist zwar
eine Traumsaison passiert ich habe es
hoffentlich der Sommer gut genossen und
hat sich gut erholt aber wenn man schon
alles gewonnen hat gleich am Anfang
eurer gemeinsamen Karriere wie setzt man
sich neue Ziele
ich würde sagen meiner ist auch das ist
immer das Ziel muss immer sein sich
selbst zu übertreffen das heißt man
natürlich ist man im Sport an andere
gebunden wann ich nicht schneller bin
wieder Italiener beispielsweise na dann
kann ich nicht gewinnen logischerweise
aber für mich wird der Sport hat doch
was mit sich selbst zum Turnen man
braucht die Einstellung dazu und
deswegen ist unser Ziel immer einfach
unsere eigenen Leistungen zu übertreffen
und nicht die von anderen
was würde das konkret jetzt bedeuten
Johannes für dieses und ja für diese
Saison ist ja da die WM als nächstes
große Event geplant und da einfach
schauen die Leistungen die letzte bei
der wm-bracht hast zum toppen und wieder
Matteo gesagt hat man tut ja Skifahrer
sagt man nicht nur wenn man das jetzt
passt die Serie auf ich brauche jetzt
nichts mehr vorn und du selber trotzdem
den Ehrgeiz noch Rost und du sitzt er
dann immer so über die Züge und schaust
es ist ja dann für diese Server immer
Bestätigung dass es weitergegangen ist
du lebst ja so gesehen von Sport und
wüsstest bist ja außer wenn und nicht so
ein alter wenn er vollgeht keiner mehr
irgendwie von und fertig weil ich habe
das
das heißt dass ihr das jetzt eher locker
angeht damit können wir nicht rechnen
also da kommt auf jeden Fall noch
einiges zu es passiert nämlich auch eine
starke Entwicklung im parasie Sport es
gibt immer mehreren auch immer mehreren
in Österreich also Heimrennen für euch
Weltcup Europa
ja es ist immer schön würde ich sagen
weil alles die Möglichkeit besteht dass
man meine Freundin und Familie wirklich
zuschauen kommen können so und ja für
mich also für uns einfach dann sowieso
unsere Lieblingsrennen weil wir einfach
das ist einfacher Hahn wo man von Anfang
an auf dem ersten Trainingstag gesagt
haben das geil das kann was und sonst
würde ich sagen kitzbühel ist eigentlich
wenn man es halt im Fernsehen immer
Sicht von dir von klar von die großen
Idole die dort haben aber gefahren sind
und wirklich das schon irgendwie was
Schönes
ihr habt ja auch die Zeit erlebt in der
der parasysport eigens organisiert war
im paralympischen Komitee seit dieser
Saison wird der parasie Sport von der
Fiss organisiert Johannes was erhoffst
du dir dafür Veränderungen
Verbesserungen vielleicht
ja
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
Aufmerksamkeit dabei sporting gewusst
ist trotzdem nur ein bisschen noch
medial ist schon passiert da ist schon
unterwegs
wirklich Aufschwung da war natürlich wir
haben es dann besonders gemerkt mit sehr
viel Interviews was natürlich extrem
schöne ist wenn man sich das kommt
anders wird von der Leid bemerkt sage
mir ganz blöd und dann steht
und da kommt irgendwer den du vorher
noch nie in deinem Leben gesehen hast
ich habe dem Fernsehen zeigen und schon
was schönes
auf jeden Fall nach dem vergangenen
Winter und jetzt mit den Leistung
gemacht dafür gesagt dass sagt andere
Auszeichnungen gefolgt sind Johannes du
bist der Sportler des Jahres mit
Behinderung geworden Matteo so eine
Auszeichnung gilt ja dann im Endeffekt
zur Hälfte auch hier ja wie wichtig ist
doch sowas
einfach so den Preis hast du ja nicht zu
ihrem Skifahren
sondern das entscheidende andere Leute
für die ob du das jetzt oder nicht und
dass man
sogar mit die Wertschätzung vom Team was
du geleistet hast noch meinen Sohn in
unserem Preis zum Grillen ist was sehr
schönes und ich glaube aber was
besonderes man sieht sie einmal entfernt
sind
und dass man dann selber waren jetzt z.B
oder ehrlich
wechselt hier ich habe wander voll geil
ein paar Wochen
das war das ja wirklich verdient weil
wir schon gesagt das ist halt wirklich
Bestätigung
für die Leistung die man erbracht hat
und da kann man auf jeden Fall noch ganz
viele dazu da bin ich mir sicher aber
bleibe kurz beim Skifahren selbst
Matteo das kurz beschrieben Johannes
wenn er runterfährt sieht das so als
wäre sie sehr nebelig jetzt grob gesagt
ja natürlich kann man medizinisch noch
in die Tiefe gehen aber das heißt die
ganze lasst sie ganz Verantwortung die
lastet auf deinen Schultern aber ist ja
nicht so dass einfach dann man fährt
runter und schalte das ist sondern das
ist ja auch alles reglementiert also
darf kein
Abstand
zu jeder Disziplin verschiedene Abstände
wo man natürlich
hinüber hinausragt wird man dies
qualifiziert was insofern oft schwierig
ist
weiß ja dann nicht geht mehr und das
gleiche gibt zwar mit dann mehr oder
weniger Mindestabstand man darf sie
nicht gegenseitig berühren das heißt der
darf mir nicht hinten auf die Spitzen
auffahren oder mir berühren das ist
ebenfalls der Disqualifikation ist das
etwas das auch im Rennen vorkommen kann
bei unserem ersten Rennen eigentlich
passiert
dass sie eben das gerade wieder das ist
aber ganz nice ist für mich gewesen
an und jetzt haben wir einen zweiten da
Dritter Windschatten auf einmal also
später mehr wichtige Rolle es bitte
Disziplinen und die erste Rennen muss
total verschlafen
ja das zu dem Zeitpunkt haben wir nicht
ganz so noch doch drüber nicht gewusst
aber seitdem wissen was also im
Endeffekt auch einen neuen Disziplin für
dich also nicht nur von selbst sondern
im Endeffekt das was du noch mit
beachten musstest fast schon ein eigener
Sport dann oder ja es ist so coole
lachen immer drüber ja man müsste das
ein bisschen vorstellen wie war mal ein
Führerschein macht mein Autofahrt zwei
Jahr lang jetzt Autofahrt und dann ist
erst einmal im Leben mit dem Hängerfahrt
toll hinter dir und du hast das Gefühl
ganze Zeit nach hinten schauen wollen
wenn du nicht genau was was da hinten
passiert es wie gesagt
leider also leider es ist halt wirklich
so du musst einfach immer bisschen
voraus denken
im Lauf ist oft sogar leichter weil man
halt besichtigen damals im Laufe von
oben bis unten in und auswendig merken
die Puppen die würden einprägen und ich
sag dann nur noch einmal ab zur
Erinnerung und primär sage dann wenn man
sie grobartig was verändert das
schwierigere ist eher dann beim
freifahren auf der Pisten weil man heute
so sehr viele Sachen passieren können
die du nicht rechnen kannst das kann
irgendeiner in der Hocke zwischen uns
durchschießen
da musste dann schnell reagieren und ja
Johannes der Anhänger von matthäuser
tatsächlich viel verändert natürlich
auch durch ihre Erfolge
was fällt euch Leute in der Vorbereitung
was funktioniert besser oder wo würdet
ihr euch noch
Verbesserungen wünschen ich glaube die
Vorbereitung läuft eigentlich gleich wie
letztes Jahr das hat eigentlich
gebastelt sie gewusst Unterschied war
war die Schnee Situation dadurch dass
das relativ warm war jetzt da im Herbst
da was relativ schwarz zum Trainieren
ist eigentlich der einzige Unterschied
und sonst haben wir heute einfach
geschaut dass man
von
die Trainings dass man Geld auch immer
funktioniert dann und da wird dann
einfach weiter drauf gearbeitet dass man
für diese Saison gerüstet haben und ich
glaube das
funktioniert der Start bis jetzt der
zeigt auf jeden Fall in die richtige
Richtung von der Weltmeisterschaft die
Ziele vom letzten Jahr also einige
Medaillen bin ich mir auf jeden Fall
sicher ich habe noch ein paar kurze
Fragen an euch als Kind wollte ich
betrifft sie jetzt jeder einzelne
beantworten
woher kam das Familie war immer
schiebegeistert und
ich habe die im Fernsehen vorhin gesehen
und für mich war immer klar ich wollte
das machen somit bin ich zum Skifahren
kommen und schlussendlich dann zum Hanse
ich glaube
die Geschwistern das ist eigentlich so
so gemacht haben und so zeigt mir dann
natürlich noch
und da ist angemerkt deine beiden
Schwestern die Lissy und die ihr müssen
ja selber auch
skigefahren und waren dann natürlich die
optimalen Guides für deine größere
Schwester also ganz ganz viele
Schwestern
[Gelächter]
ohne Sport bin ich ich glaube
einfach
irgendwas
schwierig es gibt uns ein bisschen
Festigkeit im Leben
eine Richtung und ein Ziel das ist schon
die beste Eigenschaft von Matteo und
Johannes ist also gegenseitig ist
sehr hilfsbereit
ich würde sagen der ehrgeizigkeit ist
zwar hier und da nicht gerade so positiv
von dir aber doch was ganz gutes gerade
im Sport ist es einer der wichtigsten
Eigenschaften
an Matteo oder Johannes
nervt mich am meisten
[Musik]
also fast schon
freundschaftliche Beziehung hier unser
unnützes Talent ist also was ihr
gemeinsam so richtig gut kennst was kann
man definitiv der unnötige Mundharmonika
Ehrungen ausgepackt oder
nicht und deine überlegen
[Musik]
natürlich nicht das gehen aber auf jeden
Fall wir haben es muss noch
Mundharmonika üben ich träume von
das ist eine gute Frage jetzt gerade die
Sommer Vorbereitung vorbei und der
Sommerurlaub Träume nur so ein bisschen
nach von unsere
Sommerurlaub mit unserem Wohnmobil
oder was was nimmst du was nehmt euch
noch vor was sind noch eure Ziele was
wünscht ihr euch noch
so fünf mal kurz das war damals
ja bei der nächsten Genitalien oder
wollen wir mal irgendwann kurz an die
Treffen das ist alles so ein Ziel von
uns dass man
jetzt irgendwann gerne machen würden aus
Vorläufer die Streifen
technisch skifahrerisch ungefährlich
möglich oder
gewisses Risiko ist immer erfahren das
ist irgendwie so ein Traum von beiden
machen
und ein paar Sportler Sportler ich
glaube mir voll hat fahrersportler der
die Streife wirklich im Renntempo
mitgesetzten Dorn
gefahren ist durchgehend und das war
irgendwie so am Meilenstein von uns
machen zu dürfen
wünsche euch natürlich viel Erfolg
weitere sportliche Zukunft danke für
eure bisherigen Leistungen und für mir
sicher dass ich dieser Traum auch
erfüllen wird alles Gute euch beiden
danke sehr das war es vom sportabfahrt
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal mit dabei seid bis dann und
auf Wiedersehen
[Applaus]